in 1951 in a poem titled Harlem Langston
Hughes asked a question I continue to
ask myself today what happens to a dream
deferred does it dry up like A Raisin in
the Sun when my mother was a little girl
growing up in the Nigerian village of Ososo
her and her four siblings would get
super excited whenever one of them would
accomplish something noteworthy why well
it meant that her dad would do the tree
thing that's when the smile was
stretched across his face as he climbed
a tall tree branch by branch all the way
to the very top his children down below
would look up at him eyes wide
sparkling and full of joy as he yelled
out higher higher and higher though
proud he was also never satisfied he had
a dream that his children and his
children's children would strive for
even greater things a big part of that
dream was a pursuit of an education you
see while in some families bedtime
stories are of dragons princesses and
castles in Nigerian families our stories
consists of law school med school and
Harvard and I'm only kinda joking after
all educational opportunity is what
drove my parents to trek across the
Atlantic from Nigeria to Toronto Canada
before I was born
and so throughout my high school
education I like many of you strove for
excellence with hours of study meetings
and practice all to fulfill the goal of
one day attending Harvard and on
December 13th 2013 that dream came true
I along with 2,000 other high school
seniors was fortunate enough to receive
an acceptance letter from Harvard
University and my first thought after
reading that letter was that my
grandfather in that tree and I knew it
was time to aim higher but I wasn't
quite sure yet we're doing eight months
later I was preparing for my freshman
year at Harvard little did I know events
happening over 700 miles southwest of my
home in Toronto Canada which transformed
my dream and my life forever
these events would shatter the sheltered
comfort of the life my parents had
created for me because on August 9th
2014 just over a week before I would
arrive at Harvard for the first time
Michael Brown was shot and killed by the
police in his hometown of Ferguson
Missouri through his death
I saw what happens to those whose dreams
are deferred and ultimately denied they
are left to dry up abandoned like his
dead murdered body which lay on the
streets of Ferguson under the hot
Missouri Sun for eight hours eight hours
just like me
Michael was black just like me Michael
was 18 just like me Michael was about to
go to college unlike me however he would
never get the chance to see that dream
realized and it was at that moment it
hit me after years of believing that my
grandfather's dream meant educational
attainment the accumulation of the
accolades or even acceptance to Harvard
Michael Brown's death woke me up
it made me realize the dream was about
much more than how high we can climb in
that tree as individuals it was about
how we can encourage and enable those
like Michael Brown whose dreams are
deferred and denied the climb with us
and
and while education is the essential
part of achieving that dream we often
forget it is an incomplete answer we
forget that textbooks don't do much to
teach us about compassion and that
problem sets don't necessarily teach us
about the unconditional and unfaltering
love of others we forget that whether
you are a banker a teacher or an
activist the dream should be about
creating the conditions for life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness for
everyone who walks his planet and so
while we strive to achieve our dreams
with the privileges that this Harvard
education affords us we can't forget
just how many dreams have been deferred
denied and left to drive like A Raisin
in the Sun you see I never met my
grandfather except through history of
dreams but today I stand before you as a
proud grandson of a Nigerian carpenter
the child of 2fNigerian immigrants and a
graduate of one of the greatest
institutions in the world
proof proof that while we all have
dreams some of us have to travel farther
to achieve them both figuratively and
literally my wish is that with our help
more dreams can be converted into
realities that is a calling that the
class of 2018 must answer a dual mandate
to do well and to do good to wake up
look around and help those whose crime
is stifled by the burdens of oppression
your future in my future in the future
of our society depends on us creating
supporting and investing in the dreams
that the next generation can live up to
and build upon it depends on us looking
one another in the eye and telling one
another to continue to strive for more
to keep growing and to never ever stop
climbing because the next generation is
watching looking up at us eyes wide
sparkling and full of joy as we yell out
higher higher and higher